thank you
[Music]
all right
this uh takes place in Russia my
favorite country we got a newlywed
couple this is their wedding day right
shout out they're at their wedding party
the bride is seen chatting with another
guy at the reception like of course you
would do nope the Grooms
damn that was quick no [ __ ] way not
happening the groom doesn't like level
of disrespect feels disrespected yeah as
you should what go ahead I'll let you
finish
they already feel like this now yeah
just wait turn off the groom then
goes to his new wife
takes her outside
beats her to death what death in front
of the wedding party oh and nobody did
anything they wanted to but they were
scared is he a mobster or something he's
a Russian he's just Russian okay I'll
tell you in a second after we hear from
Bart what's up
[Laughter]
what's like I used to not believe in
honor killings but these days these days
I've been kind of having to change a
heart
what about the rides uh family or
parents no one they didn't it's like
what about what was she wearing that's
that's what they said that uh the guests
at the party were trying to but then he
was like really crazy and threatening
them so they would all just keep backing
off and he was unarmed like a bunch of
dudes can't grab the guy yeah dude yeah
just Dogpile the [ __ ] guy all the
guys are in the back like yeah yeah
and then you see the guy and everyone's
like oh yeah he's scary
they were all just stuck he's not he's
more of a [ __ ] Balsam he doesn't even
look he's not a big guy really he's not
a big guy I think he's even shorter than
the wife he said he got a fire like this
no he's yeah he's definitely uh he was
not armed he just literally beat her to
death in front of everybody yeah in
front of everybody they couldn't do
anything but there's a good part of the
story right yeah what's the Silver
Lining right what's the what the
punchline oh there's a silver lining
today okay
was it his hands were broken and now
they're back in place
[Laughter]
yes
dislocated fingers it may be dislocated
guys guys he beat her to death but the
good news is he's fully recovered
I'll take my hands my arthritis is gone
my carpal tunnel oh thank God I thought
he would never be able to [ __ ] draw
again I could play trumpet once more
[Laughter]
yeah she was already a convicted
murderer you tell me if this is a silver
line because right now what's our view
we're just like [ __ ] Savage guy right
innocent
girl's trying to save himself there is a
lesson to be learned in this that's kind
of a little unexpected don't talk to
married women on their on their marriage
freshly married do not say congrats but
what was the context of the like the
conversation or they were just talking
okay what if it was like her brother
first we're gonna look at pictures of
them was she touching her hair a lot
oh dude wait this is them yeah so that's
them the zoo yeah that's them bro you
look like a female she looks bigger than
him oh never mind now he looks like a
dude I thought it was like a same-sex
relationship what yeah go back to that
first photo they look like a lesbian
double reverse photo because he looks
like a little [ __ ] right guys yeah yeah
there we go [ __ ] yeah that looks like a
same-sex relationship yep that lady on
the left looks like a [ __ ] alien dude
but the lady on the right is [ __ ]
fine
she's definitely no longer in this
universe she's the one all right she
died yeah so um so here's the lesson
okay okay
how do you think they met Tinder
like a Fight Club yeah right I was gonna
say that I was gonna say that number one
rule do not get married after fighting
yeah [ __ ] anger management did they
meet at a wedding they met because they
were pen pals while he was in prison oh
what was he in prison for murder
[Music]
thanks wife that he killed we gotta
redefine Silver Linings I don't know
he's the one bringing it up I think it's
a silver lining because this could have
been easily prevented by not being pen
pals with a [ __ ] murder and then
marrying him that's not a silver lining
it's a it's a fable something to learn
from yeah it's a brass line yeah there's
perfectly
good solid non-murderous incels in the
comments of YouTube that she could have
chosen but she even choked dude that
sucks so here's the thing her friends
said that she was aware that he was a
murder and she thought she could change
him you can't change anybody okay you
can't maybe not this guy God damn man
ladies they love those bad boys don't
they they love those bad boys huh you
can't change a [ __ ] you can't
change nobody this is why this guy
he was in jail for murder and robbery
but the wife said she believed she could
help him mend his ways she could help
him change
yeah dude if I just I'm just really
upset that the whole [ __ ] wedding
party did that's that's the part that's
shitty what would you guys do if your
daughter got with the convict and she
was a I change I can change him kind of
girl I'm in trouble dude my daughter
yeah and she brought this dude home it's
hard because his ass you know the more
just for no reason he's like welcome you
[ __ ] son of a [ __ ] you gotta
let him know on site like hey dog I can
[ __ ] you up and you got to do that and
they were like all right man now you can
date my daughter because you got to put
that fear in them yeah and the only way
you could do that with that type of
[ __ ] is if you beat his ass
right am I tripping can't be no you're
not sure what happens if you can't beat
his ass
yeah well he just [ __ ] you up he's like
six five and I'm like oh [ __ ] or what if
you beat his ass and then because the
rule is you gotta fight share one with
me to be with my daughter yeah yeah but
then I don't want to come home for
Christmas ever because you suck really
mean touch my face what if he was
actually changed and he's like so
excited to meet you hey did you [ __ ] his
ass up and then he goes back to his old
ways all right all right all right that
one failed okay sometimes you bomb
sometimes you bump
sometimes you bomb you could befriend
him right and try to find common ground
so you beat up your wife
see what kind of family we are I didn't
she's still alive you could do it I'm
the only one allowed to beat her I could
do that with your with my daughter we're
the same what I want to know is so the
guy she's talking to I assume he's
probably a nice guy and do you think
that he's watching her get beat to death
and he's like I would have never done
this
[Laughter]
he's like I always finish last because
you see those you see those situations
where the girl does not pick the nice
guy and she goes for the bad boy yeah
and then he's all like see I told you
should have been with me while she's
getting her ass beat if her friend's
family have already known for a long
time because they were dating while he
was in prison she's just been waiting
for him to get out because so they
already probably have said their peace
with [ __ ] this guy
but she's she must have a guy that's
friend zoned that's her best friend that
still secretly wants her and he was
there and he was he's the one that
dropped her off at his house while they
were [ __ ] and picked her back up and
Joel her Hall that's probably why when
she was getting beat he was like you
deserve that oh damn you think he said
that nah that's what BART said he was he
whispered in my ear and I just said that
for him there's so many reasons that you
can kind of make up for like a whole
wedding party not stepping in yeah what
the [ __ ] happened that's yeah you know
what they could have stopped that
[ __ ] out Power number he's
little dude she's bigger than him you
know what the real thing is the whole
wedding party despised her
so that's why I didn't step in to help
haters haters they were like yeah it
should have been me I should have got
married that's a lot it was a matter of
principle they're like you should not
date this guy you should not marry him
he's like no I'm in America is like hey
if some [ __ ] happens we ain't gonna stop
it all of them are eating popcorn on the
day I told you so it might be like a
whole yeah it might be a whole crowd of
uh I told you so
this is what happened oh crowd of them
objects like please say your piece they
probably all [ __ ] were like yeah yeah
winning your I mean if you're a father
I'm assuming that her dad was there it's
like
how I mean you probably gotta feel like
a little [ __ ] if you can't protect your
own family oh man okay so where's how
older daddy is though if I was 90 years
old I would [ __ ] throw my dentures at
the mother dude her dad could be that
[ __ ] Bell guy in Breaking Bad We
don't know oh yeah
you should be a brown dude they're like
why is this guy ringing the bell so much
what the [ __ ] wrong what yeah what's
going on what's going on he's seeing
this [ __ ] happen outside like where's he
looking he's looking at the birds
outside who [ __ ] knows they're doing
the [ __ ] alphabet with him it's
taking forever
so listen listen to this detailed uh
count of the of the murder itself okay
and just imagine no one is doing
anything during this whole thing oh so
they have details of what the
[ __ ] yeah so here's exactly how
it happened wrapped her hair hit her
pushed her out into the street where he
also continued to strike her body and
head once she appeared lifeless he
dumped her body into a nearby Ravine all
of this while nobody's stopping it is
that like a river it's like a ditch like
a wet ditch so there was a moment when
the body stopped moving and he picks her
up yeah and what'd he do after just go
back to the reception and say hey man
[ __ ]
where's the best man speech come on come
on that's what they're saying we still
gonna eat the cake yeah so he had his
wedding in his funeral and her funeral
at the same day because he went back and
now he's crying while he's eating his
[ __ ] borscht and everyone's like yeah
that's [ __ ] insane it was just hours
after the exchanged about and there's
probably another chick there that's like
I could change him yeah dude there's
always another one right because they
like bad boys they like projects yeah
what what is it with that that's what
I'm saying I wonder what it is to where
someone do you think it's like a
self-esteem thing probably to where they
just like they feel like that's yeah
what they're just you know yeah they
think it's like that her puppy syndrome
someone who's a guy don't treat him
right that's why
we're a bunch of nice guys yeah but hey
that's what we get such an old school
thing to treat a woman right right yeah
yeah
apparently when when he first like
berated her at the party when she was
talking to that dude what he said was
that she was behaving incorrectly and
what did she say
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]